well we were off for the long weekend
for the federal holiday Christmas for
separation of church and state but one
religion gets a federal holiday not the
topic of today's discussion but we were
off for that and the American economy
and really the country precipitating
this freefall that we are seeing under
President Donald Trump I don't even know
where to start so we'll just start with
the stock market this is of course just
one thing that is going on the stock
market totally crashing again the day
before Christmas Dow down 12.2%
year-to-date
as of Monday's closing a very erratic up
and down day today who knows where we
will end up but as of Monday's closing
the Dow down 12.2% since the first
trading day of 2018 which was January
2nd I got into a bit of a back-and-forth
with Dilbert creator Scott Adams on
Twitter where he was saying well what is
Trump actually done to precipitate the
economic troubles that we are
experiencing and isn't it all just the
fed that we can blame of course he's a
Bernie Sanders supporter very very
liberal guy to which I responded I would
love to have you on the program to talk
about this and it looks like he is going
to be back on soon so we'll be talking
to him and I will lay out the full case
as to why what Donald Trump is doing is
very bad for the economy we have Donald
Trump's cabinet increasingly empty we'll
talk about that a little bit later on as
well total disarray anyone with a good
head on their shoulders wants nothing to
do with the guy I think most sensible
people understand that more than a dozen
investigations are going on looking at
criminality and Donald Trump's business
life criminality and Donald Trump's
political life in Donald Trump's charity
life even amongst family members Donald
Trump jr. reportedly expecting an
indictment at any time we already have
even aside from the dozen plus
investigations into the president people
in prison or going to prison for crimes
committed in the course
of helping Donald Trump win we are
seeing Donald Trump ceding control of
our military to adversarial foreign
powers to the point that experts and
allies are now wondering was Trump
blackmailed into some of these decisions
I'm speaking about Syria and we'll talk
about that later on in the program the
government is shut down the government
is shut down over a temper tantrum Trump
furious with Democrats despite the fact
that Republicans control every aspect of
the administration of the federal
government at this point in time Trump
shutting down the government over a
temper tantrum and sending out erratic
and ludicrous tweets throughout
Christmas Eve and Christmas Day which we
will also get to plans for the us-mexico
border wall potentially completely dead
although Donald Trump is claiming to
have found five billion for a couple
hundred miles of that 2,000 plus mile
border how much is this entire thing
going to cost and why are we paying for
it if it's happening if Trump said that
Mexico was going to pay pay for it that
another disaster of the Trump presidency
and then and I've been talking about
this one Pat for a while
our allies are bailing out one after the
other after the other the United States
totally out of the world climate change
conversation world leaders regularly
laughing in the face of our president at
the United Nations when the guy can't
figure out how to sign a trade agreement
with the Mexican and Canadian leaders
just an absolute laughingstock and then
of course even previously claimed
victories like the denuclearization of
North Korea it's not happening North
Korea definitely not denuclearizing and
may actually be advancing nuclear
research and nuclear development who
even remembers that at this point the
Speight Donald Trump's tweets claiming
victory so we've got economic policy
that's a joke and actively destructive
Pat a deficit that's been blown up to
record numbers despite Donald Trump
saying that he's going to fix that
a trade deficit that has actually
increased despite Donald Trump claiming
that his tariffs were going to fix that
this is an administration in freefall
the likes of which we never saw under
President Obama we never saw under
george w bush despite him being a
disastrous president this is something
we have not seen for a very long time
well on the bright side it's the holiday
season that tends to be a cheery time
for many something something about
Hispanic unemployment and black
unemployment I can't remember what the
numbers are and also no one in Trump's
immediate family has yet been indicted
so that's another positive yes looking
for the silver linings in this lovely
time between Christmas and the new year
although it looks like we're getting
closer and closer to more indictments
from Robert Muller so if you can point
to something positive going on here I
know that there will be trumpets to say
well unemployment is down and I would
say yes I thought those numbers were
fake when President Obama was President
of the United States but we do have
those numbers so that's something what
will be going on in six months if you
think the last three weeks have been bad
just imagine the next six months that we
have ahead of us today's program brought
to you in part by Blink accom slash
Pakman blinka is a great service that i
use all the time what they do is they
take thousands of the most popular
non-fiction books including the newest
bestsellers they condense them into
15-minute audiobooks that you can listen
to and you still get the most crucial
information and insights from each book
and I've listened to a ton of books on
blink Asst I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book BS
Jobs by David Graeber which I listened
to on blinka they're constantly adding
new books to the platform you will never
run out of fascinating and critically
acclaimed books to enjoy and our
audience
can get a seven day free trial by going
to blink is comm slash Pakman if you're
watching on YouTube I'm putting a link
in the video description and after the
free trial if you'd like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
that's be li NK is t.com /p a que mas